you never wore a butt cream
[Music]
hi we're at the Priscilla Ono salon in
Montebello and we're here to get some
instagram-worthy nails we see a lot of
bombs in Hollywood wearing these nails
which we think is amazing because we
don't know how the hell you do that I'm
fascinated by them to be honest with you
which is why I am excited about this
challenge I don't know how they live
maybe they have nannies makeup
housekeepers before I had children I
would go get my nails done every other
week I don't get my nails done I don't
see the point I'm busy and I'm a mom and
they get dirty and they chip how long
does it take to do this an hour ago I
really hope I don't get poop under my
nails I'm just really nervous about like
the amount of bacteria that's good okay
here goes nothing operation awesome
Hollywood nails
[Music]
do you get a lot of moms in here yeah a
lot or when they're pregnant like a day
like oh this is my this is gonna be my
last set of acrylics but actually
they're coming back like after two weeks
after month feel like when I was growing
up every mom I knew had acrylic nails
it's like we press on times 1 million
I'm gonna try to pick up the phone I'm
just like lightly tapping and I'm used
to just banging on this phone and maybe
I don't need to tap so hard I feel like
I'm looking at the hands of a different
person
I feel like I'm turning into a vampire
I gave up everything good about having
opposable thumbs I did it all for beauty
I'm about to try chopsticks for the
first time with these nails let's see
okay so I had a little difficulty there
already I can feel that this nails in
the way it was challenging well I'm
gonna make my first dinner I'm a little
hesitant because I had planned on making
chicken I'm really freaked out about
touching the raw chicken cons of being a
parent with Instagram nails was actually
just like my constant fear of being
unsanitary so I came up with the
solution for my raw chicken dilemma Tom
I'm a working mom and my job involves my
hand I want to rip these nails off they
are ruining my life
watch me tight I think Morgan struggled
a lot like and I'm a professional writer
so it's not going that awesome so I just
changed someone's poo poo diaper even
though I protected my nails they still
stink I just kept feeling like oh my god
these aren't sanitary and this is so
gross they're so amazing this isn't
about motherhood but still my friend
Chrissy who I think is really awesome
and cool told me that she thought that
my nails looked awesome and then that
totally changed my whole perspective on
it she is really cool like Who am I now
am I the signage okay so I found a posit
for the nails picking food out of your
children's hair when you're a parent you
do things for your children like pick
their nose and clean out their ear wax
from time to time I think oh she did a
million times better than me with these
but my daughter is like really into them
which is the cutest so she was so into
them she went and got with my mom a
fancy accent nail pedicure for the first
time there are women who like have
mastered this I just I am NOT one of
them that feeling you get like if your
pants are too tight or like your bras
uncomfortable just like a half I can
just take this bra I could concentrate
that's how I felt now my nails are like
a brush and comb all in one so the pros
of being a mom with these nails is that
your kids pretty much always have a toy
or a shiny distraction around okay cool
so my card is stuck I don't know how to
get out I put my credit card in the
parking meter and then I couldn't get it
out too so screwed
fortunately this nice guy walked by I'm
like excuse me but can you please take
my credit card out of the reader for me
this week I lived with ten loads of
terror it was hard
they didn't really make me feel more
feminine they made me feel like I was
having more fun it was just another
accessory like an earring or like a lip
color my opinion of the women who are
able to rock motherhood with these nails
power to you sister that is badass
who knew that having these Instagram
nails would be so fun
and would be such a like fun bonding
experience for the family